[Musique]
bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres de l'actualité du week end
politique dans les yvelines le front
national a lancé sa campagne pour les
législatives vendredi dernier à
versailles
et samedi c'est le parti de la france
insoumis score organisé une réunion
publique sur le droit au logement au mur
au handball brest est ici paris se sont
affrontés au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le complexe sportif affichait complet
avec plus de 5000 spectateurs
une première depuis les mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste celui qui aime se
tenait aussi la première édition du
festival insensée à l'université
versailles saint quentin 3 jours
d'animations culturelles
nous y étions mauvais surprise ce matin
pour les usagers de la ligne n et hull
la plupart des trains étaient supprimés
la raison un mouvement de grève lancé
par la cgt hier soir les militants
demandent de plus dans bausch pour
pouvoir assurer leurs missions dans les
meilleures conditions
on écoute leur dit on se retrouve en
sous-effectif dans les triages et ce qui
permet pas d'assurer une productivité on
va dire au top ça dégrade les conditions
de travail des agents mais ça dégrade
aussi les conditions de voyage des
usagers puisqu'ils n'ont pas forcément
des trains tout le temps on a eu une
explication avec notre direction qui a
été pour le quad écoute il faut aussi le
soulever par contre on est en restera
mobilisé s'il le faut puisque ça fait
partie ce qu'on demande c'est pour le
service public et le front national des
yvelines a lancé pour a lancé sa
campagne pour les législatives vendredi
dernier 12 candidats veulent s'inscrire
dans le sillage de leur candidate à
l'élection présidentielle marine le pen
en reprenant ses axes de campagne
reportage de nicolas baudry six hommes 6
femmes les candidatures du front
national pour les élections législatives
respecte la parité des retraités des
jeunes travailleurs ou des chefs
d'entreprises déjà membre du parti
depuis plusieurs années
le but c'est d'amener à l'assemblée
nationale donc la volonté de retrouver
la souveraineté de la france de voter
toutes les lois nécessaires pour
retrouver cette souveraineté
nous n'avons absolument pas peur ni des
partis traditionnels qui ont montré
leurs failles leurs failles ni des
pseudo parti en marche un nouveau issu
de la société civile qui ne représente
rien qu'ici on le sait très bien
dévaler des banques et des banquiers
donc nous sommes très confiants
candidate dans la 11e circonscription
mathilde andraud et sera opposé
notamment au député sortant et candidat
à l'élection présidentielle benoît hamon
la manière dont il a représenté les
yvelines et particules dans sa
circonscription
cristallise tous les soucis qu'on a
rencontré ces trente dernières années de
la lâcheté en politique et
l'abandon des français face à un qu un
communautarisme et galopant territoire
rural autour de la zone urbaine de
rambouillet la 10e circonscription du
député sortant jean-frédéric poisson
le candidat du parti chrétien-démocrate
investi par les républicains présente
des similitudes avec le fn sur sa
conception de l'europe
ce qui n'inquiète pas le candidat du
parti de marine le pen le front national
et l'hymne et ligne claire ils montent
régulièrement dans la circonscription
par les 37% ce rambouillet pas sur
l'ensemble du canton
c'est vrai on est en pleine ascension le
sud des yvelines le plus rural nous
donne quasiment la majorité lors des
élections législatives de 2012 le fn
avait obtenu son meilleur score dans la
9e circonscription avec plus de 18% des
voix les candidats yvelinois espère
surfer sur la dynamique qui pourrait
être enclenchée par marine le pen lors
de l'élection présidentielle et on
continue avec de la politique l'accès au
logement était le thème d'une réunion
publique organisée vendredi dernier aux
mureaux par le collectif de la france
est soumise de jean-luc mélenchon
il a été question de mal logement mais
aussi d'écologie ou encore d'encadrement
des loyers résumé près de 12 millions de
personnes seraient touchées par la crise
du logement en france un chiffre rappelé
lors de cette réunion par les membres de
la france insoumise de jean luc
mélenchon aux mureaux comme ailleurs les
causes de la crise sont bien connus le
problème dans le pays c'est que le
logement il a trop été considéré dans
les dernières décennies comme une
marchandise comme une autre comme un
bien sur lequel on pouvait spéculer et
puis faire de l'argent fondatrice de
jeudi noir un collectif dédié au mal
logement
leila chaibi et remettent en cause
l'action de l'actuel gouvernement qui ne
serait pas allé au bout de ses promesses
avec la loi allure le problème c'est
qu'elle a été détricoté cette loi elle a
été soumise à la pression des lobbys
mobilier qu'on plus été goûtés que les
lobbies de mal logés la plus grande
inquiétude concerne les 150000 personnes
privées de tout logement sur paribas
plein de gens dans la rue
ces cinq dernières années on en a vu de
plus en plus qu'on est quand même la
salle une cinquième ou sixième puissance
mondiale
on pourrait faire un effort de
solidarité un effort de solidarité qui
doit aussi se faire sur le plan
écologique pour la france insoumise la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
passe par un habitat économe en énergie
l'effort important c'est de rénover du
point de vue isolation des bâtiments
ça ça me paraît être un point important
pour ce collectif le logement reste la
première pierre de l'insertion sociale
un chez-soi donne en effet accès à
l'école pour ses enfants et un travail
près de 650 mille personnes seraient
encore hébergées par des tiers faute de
logement personnel hier à la prison de
bois d'arcy un détenu radicaliser s'est
suicidé à deux reprises le jeune homme
de 20 ans avait tenté d'agresser les
surveillants dans l'après midi
enfermés pour une courte peine il avait
fait l'objet d'un signalement pour
radicalisation la fibre se déploie
encore un peu plus dans les yvelines
c'est maintenant au tour de bois d'arcy
devant élèves et le prochain une
convention sera signée entre la commune
et le prestataire orange par 2017 c'est
le quartier de la croix bonnet qui sera
relié en premier toute la commune
devrait l'être en 2019 écoutez le maire
philippe benassaya quelles étaient nos
demandes c'est qu'on était dans une
ville qui a un qui fait du numérique une
priorité de la mandature
donc nous avons fait beaucoup de choses
à ce sujet et nous leur avons demandé de
prendre en compte cet effort du
numérique sur la ville et donc on s'est
revus on a eu beaucoup de négociations
beaucoup de discussions qui ont été très
difficile et on a pu anticiper un peu
accéléré le déploiement de la fibre à
bonnart si le vélo de route nationale
fêtant l'anniversaire ce vendredi celui
des 50 ans de la caisse du crédit mutuel
de saint quentin en yvelines pour ce
rendez-vous de 150 personnes étaient
présentes dont le pistard de l'équipe de
france françois pervis on écoute le
président du conseil d'administration
daniel gérard doz au micro de michael et
le midh auront écouté 50 ans pour tout
le monde je pense que c'est beaucoup
comme je vous le disais autour de nous
il ya un certain nombre de caisses qui
ont deux ans trois ans cinq ans et nous
c'est 50
donc c'est vraiment un beau
développement et on est tous très fiers
des 50 ans de la caisse
il veut dire qu'on était l'une des
premières caisses du crédit mutuel de la
région parisienne au resto vélodrome et
pari réussi ce week end pour le match de
gala entre brest et issy paris handball
le complexe sportif affiché complet avec
plus de 5000 spectateurs
une première depuis les mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et de nicolas d'andry 17h30 vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs milliers de supporters
arrivent pour assister au choc de d1
féminine entre issy paris et brest
pouvoir le match idéal on est là parce
qu'on a deux joueurs de hand et que
voilà on c'est un événement dans le coin
qui est super sympa donc on y vient en
famille on est content d'être là du
monde il y en avait le match délocalisé
se jouent à guichet fermé avec 5415
spectateurs dans les travées
cette affluence permet de dépasser le
précédent record pour un match de
handball féminin qui était jusqu'ici
détenu par nantes avec 5125 supporters
le record était effectivement une envie
pas forcément l'objectif principal
l'objectif principal ce trader
de réussir les vêtements
avec tout le territoire et tous publics
donc ça c'est
je suis très heureux de sa vie pensé
réussir pour ce premier match de
handball de l'histoire organisé dans
l'enceinte sportive certains n'ont pas
hésité à faire 600 km pour venir
assister à la rencontre et mettre
l'ambiance
nous on suit toujours de très quelques
favoris soutenir le brésil au taillan
balle on essaye on essaie de faire les
déplacements à chaque fois qu'on peut et
c'est vrai que ici dans cette enceinte
de du vélodrome c'est parfait se
croirait à l'aréna de brest
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce supporter de brest avait moins le
sourire à la fin de la rencontre le
match s'achève avec une victoire au
forceps d'ici paris contre les bretonnes
sur le score de 24 à 23 selon les
joueuses parisiennes l'appui du public a
été primordiale dans ce résultat
franchement on avait à coeur de bien
faire ici sur le stade vélodrome est
montré qu' on a des le succès rencontré
cette année le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le club
d'issy paris envisage déjà un second
partenariat pour l'année prochaine cela
mérite bien un clapping
[Musique]
et à quelques mètres de là l'université
versailles saint quentin se tenait la
première édition du festival insensé
trois jours d'animations culturelles
samedi matin le festival a investi la
zone commerciale avec une parade
reportage difficile de les rater samedi
la troupe de lascars avant d'ouvrir la
parade du festival un sens et une
déambulation de l'université versailles
saint quentin au centre commercial
l'idée c'était de créer un événement
fédérateur en arrivant à contacter les
associations locales de saint quentin en
yvelines
les associations étudiantes est vraiment
de pouvoir construire un événement tous
ensemble est un événement qui nous
ressemble à un événement qui est pour
saint quentin en yvelines pour ses
habitants et donc pour nous c'était
important de créer cette dynamique
culturelle vraiment entre chaque acteur
de l'événement
une dizaine d'associations saint
quentinois s'étaient donné rendez vous
deux d'entre elles pour un projet commun
pris en compte
deux ans de travail pour vivre debout et
les black blanc beur
pour fêter dont 40 ans des avions décidé
de faire un événement festif faire la
fête et faire la fête autour en fait de
vos histoires personnelles de ce qui
vous est arrivé dans la vie les bonnes
et des mauvaises choses mais raconter ça
avec humour est et d'une façon agréable
ça a été fait sur la base de mathieu
donc moitié me trouvais graf qui est un
petit peu
à s'enfuir lagarde travail
chorégraphique en fait et puis elle nous
on s'est greffée à deux ans en fait quoi
tout simplement
voilà donc ces beaux dirais je dirais
que c'est beaucoup furent ainsi de nous
adapter à leur situation que de
s'adapter à notre manière de bouger en
fait soleil et instant de bonne humeur
pour l'arrivée du printemps où l'on a
même vu en géant tombé amoureux c'est la
fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci de nous
avoir suivis prochaine édition demain
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]